politicians and bureaucrats spend a lot
of their time making new laws and
regulations to protect the public but
now that has really hit the fan even the
government is realizing how many of
those are unnecessary here are 10
measures created in the name of public
safety that have been set aside in the
name of public safety
the CDC testing monopolies perhaps the
biggest and most obvious [ __ ] on
the list the agency mandated that only
it could create and distribute tests and
when they finally did roll them out they
turned out to be painfully slow and
wildly inaccurate only after this
colossal failure did they allow private
companies into the game which has led to
more testing kits that deliver faster
results
if only that had happened months ago HHS
is issuing a regulation today that will
allow all doctors and medical
professionals to practice across state
lines that is fantastic news except for
the fact that HHS doesn't have that kind
of authority each state has jurisdiction
over who can practice their not
surprisingly HHS has been pretty quiet
about the issue but at least some states
have waived restrictions making it
easier for doctors to be doctors you
know things are serious when the TSA is
easing stupid restrictions since 2006
the agency said that having more than
3.4 ounces of liquid in a container was
super dangerous on airplanes but now
that actual danger is around and no one
is flying
hand sanitizer in 12 ounce bottles is
a-ok speaking of hand sanitizer here's
some good news from the alcohol and
tobacco tax and trade Bureau also known
as the TTB because Howell distilleries
around the country can now make hand
sanitizer without jumping through a
metric fuckton of red tape including
permits bonds authorization formula
approval and taxes these waivers are
only approved through June 30th however
after which that same hand sanitizer
might once again be very dangerous
anyone who makes ourselves alcohol is
well-versed in ridiculous and
counterproductive regulation but with
the crushing blow social distancing
brings two restaurants at least one
strip of red tape is being snipped state
and local governments are lifting bans
on alcohol home delivery which is
welcome news to bars restaurants and
anyone stuck at home paying attention to
the news the FDA has been easing a bunch
of restrictions including relaxing rules
on ventilator manufacturing allowing
pharmacists to make hand sanitizer
declaring previously unapproved
respirators as totally safe now allowing
outside groups to make
agnostic tests easing access to
antiviral drugs allowing the use of
medical devices that remotely measure
vital signs and allowing veterinarians
to utilize telemedicine which was
previously prohibited because Medicare
is now paying for telemedicine visits
which makes a lot of sense for people
who can't leave their house easily or
are greater risk of infection which come
to think of it as basically everyone who
is on Medicare to begin with HHS said
that even though they don't fully
conform to HIPAA rules regarding privacy
and security doctors may now use Skype
and FaceTime for telemedicine because
the future is now or at least it was 17
years ago numerous states are freeing
nonviolent offenders who are put behind
bars for technical violations or because
they simply couldn't afford bail site
and release policies are also being
enacted across the country keeping
low-level offenders out of jail if there
is no risk to the community and it's a
pretty damning admission by authorities
that for a long time they've been just
fine with locking people up who posed no
risk to the community and plastic bags
are back baby after a hot and heavy
fling with reusable grocery bags
politicians are waking up to realize
that canvas totes have a secondary
function as microbial party buses so
what once was banned is now required and
vice versa but in the name of public
safety subject to change
[Music]